[Music]
hello
i'm alexander rose the executive
director here at long now
i'm coming to you from upstairs behind
the bookshelves at the interval from the
offices of the long now
genevieve bell will be joining us live
from australia to watch this edited
version of her talk tonight and will be
answering questions afterwards from you
as well as kevin kelly from the long now
board
genevieve has spent a career first at
intel and more recently with her own new
institute
trying to understand the relationship
between humans and technology
i like to think of her work as trying to
answer whether or not technology has a
soul
and possibly more importantly do we
actually want it to
welcome genevieve bell hi and thank you
for that incredibly gracious
introduction
it's really uh daunting to be here
the role call of people in this seminar
series is a roll call
of people who built the world that we
live in and who built the world that
i've inhabited for the last 25 years
what i wanted to do over the next half
an hour was unfold a story about the
fourth industrial revolution and the
three that preceded it and the questions
that they raise
for me and hopefully for you and the
kinds of ways we ought to be thinking
about the future and how we want to
inhabit and live in it
there are lots of ways to introduce
myself and lots of ways to talk about
who i am and why i care about these
issues but
here are the important pieces what you
need to know is that i'm an
anthropologist
uh by training and by birth in some ways
i'm the daughter of an anthropologist
too i grew up on my mother's field sites
in central and northern australia in the
1970s and 1980s
i grew up in aboriginal communities with
indigenous people who remembered their
first sight of cattle
and of europeans and offenses and not
always in that order
and who for the arc of my childhood took
me on to their country told me their
stories and taught me how to be in that
place
it was an extraordinary childhood uh
it's a really long way from
those places in the northern territory
to america and to silicon valley in
particular
where i have worked on and off for the
last well nearly 25 years
i did my phd at stanford my area of
expertise was native american ethno
history feminist and queer theory
you can imagine how that background
lands you a job at intel
the only real good answer to that
involves the 1990s the dot-com boom
and a bar in palo alto that's long since
gone
but in my time at intel my
responsibility was to
help bring insights about what people
care about what frustrates them what
they want for themselves their kids
their countries their communities
and bring all those insights into the
way we make new technology and drive
different kinds of technical innovation
effectively my job was to haunt the
building with the voices of the people
who couldn't be there otherwise
to put people back into the way we build
technology or sometimes just put them
into the way we build technology
that was an extraordinary gig it was an
extraordinary
place to be and it was an amazing set of
adventures
three years ago i decided to come back
to australia and return to my hometown
and help build a new set of adventures
here at the australian national
university
i get to spend my days and my time
thinking about what
it means to build the future and what it
means to build
next-generation technical systems but
because i'm sitting in australia
there's a way we like to begin all talks
and all conversations with what we would
call an
acknowledgement of country and i want to
begin by acknowledging the traditional
owners of the land upon which i'm
standing today this is not a wall on
ambry land always sacred and never
seated and i want to pay my respects to
the elders past
and present of this place i also want to
acknowledge that this conversation is
unfolding
across many places today and i want to
pay my respects to traditional alders
and elders of all those places too
it means a lot to me to get to say that
it means a lot
to me to get to think about and be
responsible for
paying attention to the places we find
ourselves and of remembering that we
live in a country that's been
continuously occupied for nearly 60 000
years
here in australia aboriginal people
built a world and a world system
they built technologies they built ways
to manage this place
and they did it at levels and with
degrees of complexity that
are genuinely remarkable and for me
every conversation about the future
unfolds in a place that's always been
built in the future
and that responsibility to tell those
stories and to carry through
that knowledge is part and parcel of why
i'm happy to be home and why i take it
incredibly seriously to remember
where i am and what that place's history
is
and i wanted to share just a little bit
of that history with all of you because
i know that
may sound unexpected and i wanted to
talk a little bit about a system that's
built here in australia
it's on the border of queensland and new
south wales it's on
a river system called the barwin and
it's
literally inside a town called bawarna
which is sitting right on the barwin
river
so in this town called bowona there is
today
an archaeological site uh it's the site
of a series of
fish traps it's the largest and oldest
set of fish traps
in australia it's nearly two kilometers
long and it's a series of
stones made in the shape of fishnets and
what this entire system did
over this massive piece of a river was
create the capacity to trap fish whether
they were going upstream
or downstream and to hold them in pens
in cool running water
when the water was low and when the
water was high and the reason that you
did that here on this river was that it
was a meeting place it was a place where
multiple different nations gathered
it was a place where multiple families
gathered and it was a place where
ceremonies and ritual
and knowledge was built and exchanged
and in order to make that happen you
needed to have food at scale
the most remarkable thing about this
system archaeologists estimate its age
to be 40 000 years old
it is in fact the oldest known technical
system
built by humans on the planet the last
time we have a recorded use of this
system
is in about 1915 so if you're sitting
somewhere listening to this
and you've built a technical system
imagine building a technical system that
would last for 40
000 years most of us are lucky if we
built a system that lasted for 10
is also a system that suggests an
understanding of
technologies in this case lithics stone
it's a system that suggests an
understanding of the ecosystem and the
environment
and one that was changing over this
period of time and it's a system that
suggests a profound
insight into how human beings work and
for me those three pieces
technical cultural and ecological are
incredibly significant
as we think about building technical
systems we need to build them with
multiple pieces in mind not just the
technology
but the ecological piece and the human
piece
it's a useful way of framing how the
current technical systems
should and could unfold so if that's a
story of a technical
social cultural system i'm willing to
bet most of you haven't heard about
i wanted to switch gears a little bit
and move 40 000 years forward and talk
about some systems i suspect many of us
know a little bit better
this is a chart published by the world
economic forum in 2016
it's a chart that crystallized a
conversation that had been circling for
quite some time about this
notion of the fourth industrial
revolution what the world economic forum
did in 2016 was give that conversation
form and structure what they also did
was give the fourth industrial
revolution a backstory
they made it part of a series of earlier
waves of
history and waves of economic and
technical transformation
of course in doing that they also
stabilized both that
history and the context and consequences
of that history that
also made a fetish of the technical
systems and in some ways made quite
mysterious what the consequences of
those transformations had been to human
society
to culture and in some ways what's also
missing from this story
is the story of who made that possible
and both individual biographies and the
kind of practices and practitioners that
had to develop
so what would happen if you revisit all
these revolutions with an either two
questions
what did it take to get to scale in each
one of those moments and what did scale
look like
and the reason for asking those
questions of the first three industrial
revolutions is to help position
ourselves to think more critically about
this fourth one
so the first industrial revolution
starts in many places
but one of them is cornwall in 1712 atop
a mine
with a man named thomas newcomen
newcomen was an iron monger
and a preacher and a man who
occasionally
helped save miners from the bottom of
flooded mines
it's in that latter context that he
helped come up with the idea of the
atmospheric engine
which is really the prototype of all
steam engines to follow
he was an inventor and an innovator and
in 1712 he took a whole lot of other
people's ideas and built them into a
single object it was two stories high
it was loud it consumed everything
around it water and coal
and it also changed everything too it
took a while before anyone worked out
just what a powerful object this was
it's 20 years before you get to 100 of
these objects in circulation it's nearly
100 years before you get to 2000
but in that slow steady ramp of the
atmospheric
engine with watts transformations in it
into the steam engine
what you see is an object that moves
from mines into factories
and changes the way factory work is done
it changes the possibilities of how
things can be built
it makes a series of complicated
cultural and practical transformations
but in some ways the most important
moment of scale isn't that first century
but the second
and it comes in 1829 at a place called
rain hill in england
when a locomotive called the rocket
changes
the way we thought about steam engines
they go from being stationary to mobile
they go from being powerful to being
fast
and in so doing unleash the possibility
of creating networks of trains and
railway systems
but to get to a railway system required
more than just a locomotive
it required regulation regulation that
fixed
train prices so that everyone could have
access to the technology
that managed safety so that the trains
didn't hurt people
that change the ideas about how time
should be configured so the trains would
run on time
it took ideas about timetables ideas
about
who had rights in land it took
regulations
it took all kinds of new practitioners
ticket takers
and safety inspectors and civil
engineers
and those train systems unfolded in
britain
and the united states and australia and
japan
and india and in so doing transformed
the way we thought about
time and distance and about speed
the irony of course in all of this is
that industrial revolution
was nearly two centuries in the making
so getting to scale in this instance
took time and it required all manner of
regulations and social actors and
practice to be accomplished
so if the first industrial revolution is
anchored on steam
the second industrial revolution is
anchored on electricity but it's many of
the same challenges
the unfolding of electricity takes
decades
the very first displays of electricity
are in the 1850s at the crystal palace
in england as a spectacle at world
expositions
world fairs the battle of light in paris
in 1881
it is an ongoing thing even the great
white way
in new york city where you took people
to see electricity was all about how did
you convince people that they needed
this new
infrastructure because people had ways
of lighting their homes and powering
things they had steam they had
gas why did they need electricity so
part of the challenge for the second
industrial revolution was actually
compelling people to imagine they should
upgrade
of course it also required whole new
systems
it wasn't just enough to make light and
make
power it required having someone to
generate the power it inquire required
an electrical grid it
required an incredible argument about
what was the best way to configure that
grid ac or dc what was the best way to
imagine
doing all the work you needed to do to
upgrade and retrofit buildings what new
appliances and experiences would need to
be created
it took individual actors in different
countries
it took an entire apparatus to get to
scale
whether it is in fact thomas edison in
the united states who not only
gets light bulbs down to a reasonable
price that they can be marketed but
builds the first electrical power plants
in order to generate the electricity to
make the lights work
in britain getting electricity to scale
required civic and civil organizations
it required people like carolyn hazlitt
and the electrical association for women
that helped empower british housewives
and homemakers
to troubleshoot their own appliances and
keep things running
it required a whole set of different
conversations with businesses
and all of that much like the first
industrial revolution took
time from the first experiments with
electricity to the first electrification
of
power into manufacturing facilities is
nearly 50 years
and the consequences of changing mass
production or making mass production
we also had to build new kinds of
companies new kinds of business models
new kinds of corporations
and even new kinds of practitioners so
much like that first industrial
revolution getting to scale was a
complicated puzzle
for the third industrial revolution it's
the one that for many of us in the room
we may remember some of the beginnings
of this
the third industrial revolution is about
automation and digitization
and the technology that is required to
take to scale here is the computer
starting with the earliest computers in
the 1940s
you really don't hit ubiquity of the
object until the 1960s
but part of what really takes computers
to scale in this instance isn't just the
availability of computers
it's the creation of two things
programming languages that let people
talk
to computers and let them do things
beyond the obvious but also the
invention of a
curriculum for computer science to help
bring a whole lot of people into the
conversation
so starting in the early 1960s there
were a number of people all over the
united states who were using computers
in their research jobs and in
their professional jobs and starting in
the mid-1960s a whole collection of
different people at american
universities started to imagine what
would it be like
to teach people to use these computers
so that they weren't
just branded objects sitting inside
companies but they could become
platforms upon which many things could
happen
by 1968 an initial curriculum has been
created to teach computer science it
gets called computer science because up
until then it was computing
there is now a curriculum that
curriculum does two things
it creates the possibility that a whole
lot of people can have a shared
experience and a shared vocabulary
it also creates the possibility that all
the ways you could think about computing
is no longer tied to the objects of now
but creates the possibility of other
objects to come
into existence it's kind of remarkable
for me to imagine that that first
curriculum first saw the light of day at
stanford university where i did my phd
you can still go and look at that
original curriculum you can see the
first textbook that was produced by
george forsyth and his remarkable wife
alexandra
that textbook is amazing if only because
when you open it you think yeah those
are all pretty much still the things we
need to think about
it has a lovely way of describing an
algorithm and some glorious examples for
how to think about things
but imagining what it took to get a
piece of technology to scale in the 20th
century
involved commercial enterprises it
involved universities and it involved
the creation of a vocabulary
and a set of questions that would let
many more people
engage with those machines and do things
with them that were unimaginable
it also of course involved the
continuing evolution of the technical
system
it involved things like moore's law and
companies like intel and amd continuing
to revolutionize and innovate on those
technical platforms
it involved the creation of a whole lot
of other objects that
took on compute power and made them
meaningful
but again it took time it took social
actors
it took an extraordinary number of
practitioners and
it still much like the first two
industrial revolutions not entirely done
yet
and that gets us to the fourth
industrial revolution anchored around
the notion of
ai the first stories about ai or the
first time that
term was coined 1956 dartmouth
june july and august but really we've
been talking about machines
thinking long before that at the macy's
conferences
in new york city in the 1940s and 1950s
with alan turing at bletchley park and
manchester in the united kingdom
they've been many conversations about
what it might mean to make machines
think
like humans the unfolding of ai and the
accumulation of
expertise and theories and practice has
been
decades in the unfolding but when we
talk about the fourth industrial
revolution we're talking about more than
just ai
we're talking about ai as part of a
system and we're talking about a system
that is going to have to expand to
include not just
ai but the systems in which it finds
itself
the internet of things fast and rapid
telecommunications protocols
all of it ultimately also built on the
second and third industrial revolutions
of the computing platform and the
electrical grid
of course it's an industrial revolution
that's in the beginning stages
the technology is 60 years old but what
it will mean to go
successfully to scale feels like
something that is going to take a whole
lot of incredible complexity
and raise a whole lot of really quite
complicated questions
for me i think it's easy to talk about
scale scale is clearly the logic that
runs through the industrial revolution
along with ideas about efficiencies
and ideas about productivity i want to
suggest that this fourth wave is a light
slightly different than the waves that
come before it
we have that history it doesn't just
inform how we think but it could help us
ask better questions about the future
that is coming
i want to be concerned about what it
means to have safe
responsible and sustainable cyber
physical systems
not just productive and efficient ones
what would it mean to say that the
systems we are building
shouldn't just go to scale but they
should go to scale in a way that feels
like something we can live with
after all when we talk about the first
industrial revolution we could also talk
about the luddites
we could talk about pollution we could
talk about the consequences of chopping
down so much lumber to feed those
inexhaustible trains
if we talked about the second industrial
revolution and electricity we could also
talk about what it meant
to have mass production and what that
meant to ideas about
labor and what it meant to factory
conditions if we talk about the third
industrial revolution and computing we
can talk about notions about
privacy and trust and security and risk
and all of the energy it takes to make
those systems functional
there are many cautionary tales inherent
in all those earlier industrial
revolutions
and for me imagining what it means to
build the fourth one in a manner that we
can all live with feels like we should
be paying attention to those lessons too
and lurking in all those stories about
the earlier industrial revolutions are
also stories about the people who made
it possible
not just the business owners and the
inventors but the practitioners and the
workers who made those systems go to
scale safely
engineers electrical engineers computer
scientists
and who are going to be those
practitioners for that fourth wave
and so part of the reason i came back to
australia was that i was convinced
that we needed something different that
this fourth wave of the industrial
revolution demanded a different set of
conversations and a different set of
skills
and for me i think what it actually
requires is establishing a new
branch of engineering and that's what
we've been doing here at the institute
that
i run at the australian national
university no small thing
always helps to have spent 20 years in
silicon valley you can kind of square
your shoulders and say yep i'm
establishing a new branch of engineering
right here we go of course that's easier
said than done
if you want to establish a new branch of
engineering there are some big questions
you need
to be asking questions about who are
going to be those practitioners what
would you teach them
what would their jobs look like how
would that unfold
so at the institute we've been doing a
couple of things we kicked off a new
educational program two years ago we
figured well if you need to build a
branch of engineering you could just try
teaching it into existence
radical experiment we also tried to
study it into existence so go look at
places where cyber physical systems are
already happening and look at what the
both
problems and perils and possibilities
have been
or you could go at it another way which
is to think about what are the kind of
questions you would need to ask of those
systems and how would you go about
answering them
the good news in all of this is that
establishing branches of engineering
is whilst non-trivial it's also not a
new thing first branches of engineering
were established
in paris with the echo polytechnic at
stanford with computer science
at wharton with business schools so
there's lots of ways of thinking about
this right but we thought we should
start with some questions
and for us there are six big ideas that
help you think about how to build those
systems how to regulate those systems
how to decommission those systems
how to operate safely with those systems
first question is is that cyber physical
system really autonomous and if so what
does that mean
how do you engineer it how do you secure
it how do you regulate it
how do you think about what that
actually means from a policy point of
view because not autonomy is
built the same way how do you think
about whether those systems have
agency or put another way what are the
controls and limits on those systems and
where do they sit are they inside the
systems are they outside the systems
are they software are they hardware who
gets to activate them and under what
circumstances how do you secure them
how do you evolve them over time because
surely those systems will change
over time think back to the steam
engines
third set of questions have to do with
assurance how do you know if the system
is
safe reliable trustworthy how do you
configure risk and liability how do you
think about
privacy and trust manageability
explicability legislation
ethics standards it is an entire
portfolio of questions that require
work and attention how do you think
about what the indicators of those
systems are going to be
as in what are going to be the metrics
we used to know if cyber physical
systems are working well
or not much of the first three ways of
the industrial revolution centered on
ideas about efficiencies and
productivities
i think we could also reasonably ask
ourselves about safety
and sustainability how would we make
those into indicators what would the
matrices be and who would get
to look at them and think about them of
course cyber physical systems
at scale also raise questions about
interfaces and interactions how we're
going to engage with those systems will
we engage with them will they engage
with each other
what will that all look like and what
will it mean to have a whole series of
technologies with which we are
deeply familiar suddenly change their
behavior
if you put ai inside an elevator bank
the elevators behave differently and as
humans we stand there
trying to work out why there are no
buttons inside the lift compartment we
find ourselves in
how we build interfaces to those next
generation technical systems
is an open and interesting challenge
and the last question which is sometimes
also the first question
what are the intentions of these systems
why are they being built
what is the idea of the world that they
are making and promulgating
and how might we critically interrogate
that idea
big questions back ending those
questions
is just a little bit of cheeky
and retro theory i don't think you can
talk about
cyber physical systems without dwelling
on the systems piece and the cyber piece
and for me that means going back to the
work that was done in the 1940s by
norbert vena and at the macy's
cybernetics conferences
for norbert the notion of cybernetics
was the scientific study of control
and communications in animals in the
machine for his colleagues these were
conversations about how did you imagine
a world
where the system would need by necessity
to include technology
culture and the ecology but if you go
back to those early conversations in the
1940s and you go back to those
first attempts to imagine what
cybernetics might be
it wasn't so much about computing as it
was about technology
and it wasn't so much about computing as
it was about the notion of sophisticated
technical systems and whilst we now
understand cybernetics as being about
computing it wasn't always that way the
earliest conversations at the macy's
conference were about how the brain
worked about how systems worked
about how animals and humans learnt they
were about what we dreamed they were
about what we talked about
and for norbert and many of those early
conversationalists
cybernetics was as much about the system
and about the feedback loop as it was
about the technology upon which it later
came to be built
in reaching back to cybernetics as one
of the theoretical underpinnings of this
new branch of engineering what i hope
we're also doing is creating space to
imagine different ways of thinking about
technology one of the most remarkable
things about the
warren of fish traps is to imagine this
is a technical system that is hundreds
of years in the making
this is a technical system that required
concerted and continuous
effort this was not a quick fix this is
not a quick software drop overnight
this is something that required
generations both of
accumulated knowledge about how the
environment worked accumulated knowledge
about hydrology and about fish
but also an accumulated commitment to
continuing to build sustain
and upgrade that system over time
and i think about the fact that it was
possible to be cybernetic without
computing
and i wonder what lessons we can pull
through from that original system
ideas about sustainability ideas about
systems that are decades or centuries in
the making
ideas about systems that endure and
systems that are built explicitly
to endure and systems that are built to
ensure the continuities of culture
feel to me like the kind of systems that
we might want to be investing in now in
the 21st century
and so for me when we think about using
cybernetics as a tool
it's also about being able to bring
through those
older more enduring stories and finding
a way to theorize them
alongside and in partnership with
contemporary technology
and so as we imagine these cyber
physical systems this fourth wave of the
industrial revolution
the piece for me isn't just about how do
we build them and think about their
economic consequences is also how do we
theorize them and in theorizing them how
do we
ensure that we are asking the right
questions about those systems
and insisting that certain pieces sit
inside those systems
so talking about an ai
driven world and ai ready society a
cyber physical
system world without also talking about
the people piece and the environmental
piece is for me a conversation only half
had
so as we start to build the next
industrial revolution as we start to
build the new branch of engineering here
for us it's about how do we take those
questions and those technical systems
but also
insist over and over again that people
and the environment need to be part of
it too
so here's the thing that being in
silicon valley taught me
acutely is that whilst we may tell
stories about
lone inventors we never actually do it
alone so
i need help if you're crazy enough to
stand up and say you're going to build a
new branch of engineering you should
never do it alone
i've been lucky enough to have all kinds
of people come and join me on this mad
adventure
and we are just in the process now of
recruiting for our third
cohort of students applications are open
now
you can find the url right here if you
suddenly feel a need or you can think of
someone who should be
participating in this please send them
our way and if you
are interested in any of this
conversation will you find us because
i don't want to do this by myself and i
don't think we should do it alone and i
think this is a conversation that should
involve
well many many different voices as many
voices as we can possibly sustain
because fourth industrial revolution
requires a different approach than the
previous three and i want to ensure that
approach
is one that is deeply embedded in
conversations about
safety and sustainability and
well responsibility and for me that
conversation is one that
requires as many different people as i
can so the invitation
is there and with that i want to stop
and say thank you
thank you genevieve that was fantastic
um we're going to be pulling your feet
in
from australia live as well as from
kevin kelly here in california
welcome genevieve hi hey
hey guys uh so i mean i realized as i
was doing a search for your email
genevieve that the first email exchanges
we had i think are in 1998
from when you were an advisor to the
rosetta project and i'd kind of
forgotten how long that had gone back
but it's great to kind of come full
circle now um
with you here and and the um your
opening
example of this 40 000 year system that
um that was used in australia uh
to catch fish what i love about it is it
was clearly so iterative
and you know while it was a big system
any
child with the right knowledge could
walk out and put a rock and
and repair it in a way um or help it um
or hurt it to a certain extent i guess
by taking a rock away
but the um the the friendliness the kind
of
of that technology and its iterative
nature is so unlike the technologies
that we have now
that seem so fragile
but can you say a little bit about why
it stopped
being in use about 100 years ago it's a
story about what happens when an
indigenous system
runs headlong into a colonial expansion
so that river was a river being used by
boats
to move goods and services around it was
a river that had a series of
european dams and water containment
strategies
implied upon it it was also a system
where early settlers saw those rocks
that were beautifully worn from all that
time in the river and took rocks out of
that system and used them to build the
foundations of many buildings around the
river system
and it's also a system the custodians
of it found themselves being moved off
that country
and not able to be there and move across
their land in the ways they had so
the decline of that system is also a
story about
the unfolding of and the clash of
cultures and technical systems
today there is a really quite
extraordinary cultural museum on that
side and the local
elders and traditional owners of that
place are slowly steadily rehabilitating
the
site and the weir and the river and the
water flowed through it for the first
time
in about five years just this winter
when we had rain again
yeah that's very cool um i
i think one of the things you mentioned
towards the end also is that
this fourth revolution like all the
other revolutions are kind of defined by
the people
that that build it and um how how are
you seeing
that more voices more cultures are being
invited into
the the way this fourth revolution comes
about
alison it's such a good question uh
xander because i think there is this way
what we think about the first industrial
revolution and
most of our uh i think our imagination
is occupied
by the dark satanic mills in britain
right it really does have that kind of
feel to it
mass production and electricity feels
like an american story
and in some ways a midwestern story ah
computing feels very much like a west
coast
story i think the remarkable thing that
we have seen over the last well 20 years
that we've all been
in conversations is that centers of
innovation
and creation are now visible to all of
us i think they were always there but
they're
visible in many other places whether it
is the work that goes on
in india in israel
in latin america in china across the
greater asian kind of ring of countries
there are multiple centers of innovation
and invention in this space both in
terms of
what ai will be and how it's being um
sort of unfolded but also the systems
into which it is being
employed and i think even increasingly
in
places like silicon valley and other
more traditional centers we are seeing a
diversity of voices and experiences
never enough as far as i'm concerned but
at least it's an improvement on what it
was 20 years ago
right a lot of those pictures that you
had of those early inventors were pretty
much all white guys
and there's always there's always other
people in those stories but the amount
of work you have to do to go find them
is kind of the perennial bit about how
do we ensure that we're telling
telling stories about our histories that
are actually closer to what was really
going on and not the story that gets
sort of
happily retold so i think there are
always places we can
put back experiences that were relevant
into those stories but you're right
that's uh it's a narrow band
well one more before i hand it off to uh
kevin for a couple
questions but uh renata barretto from uh
facebook
um she she points out that you mentioned
scale several times in the
early year revolutions um and that
and wants to know how that fits into
scaling issues
for um for this fourth revolution i
think in a way
what's funny about this one is that it's
kind of scales
the scale is almost daunting of of this
current revolution
um not so much in that we have to build
it and that is upon us and then how do
we enter into that scale
in a human way yeah i think the
interesting thing for me about scale
is both the ways in which it's often
only visible when it breaks
so you know if you think about some of
the infrastructures of the 20th century
they only became clear to us when they
stopped working so i think about the
massive power outages
in northern california late last year
i think about the bushfires that ran
through australia over our holiday
periods at the end of last year into the
beginning of this year where our
electrical grid was suddenly compromised
as was our telecommunications grid
and i think there's a piece about some
of those scales felt inevitable and now
seem much more brittle than they were
and then for this most recent wave part
of the scale has been
likewise invisible i mean part of what
made the ai
revolution if you want to describe it is
that over the last decade possible was
the abundance of data
and data is often invisible to us until
it's played back to us both either in
the breacher but where we suddenly go
hey wait how did you know that
or when we see the collection practices
that were otherwise in some ways quite
subterranean being held
in clear light and for me one of the
complicated things about scale in this
moment
is both that there are ubiquitous
systems that are quite uh
brittle and then there are
subtler pieces at work that are not yet
visible and somewhere in the combination
of those two things is scale
yeah i think um my favorite definition
of technology from danny hillis is it's
the stuff that doesn't quite work yet
and in the case of things like the
electrical grid re-failing it's
it's falling back into the to the term
of technology instead of just the things
we take for granted
oh for me you know the the arc of the
beginning of the 21st century has been
a series of stories we tell about
technologies that are reliant on things
that we thought were stable in the 20th
century that are nowhere near as stable
as we thought they were and not just
technical systems social ones too
right how do we think about civic and
civil society how do we think about
ideas about democracy
all of those feel differently brittle
too
kevin yeah um so jennifer your
categories of the four revolutions i
think is really brilliant and
right on um but i have an impression
that unlike maybe the first three
revolutions that
people in on a large scale are
talking about this revolution before
it's actually happened
i mean the number of discussions almost
like this one
where we're talking about ai long before
there really
is any ai i think is kind of unique
in the sense that i don't think um the
first three revolutions people were
talking about
the consequences of electricity years
before everybody had it
is is this a correct assessment
i suspect for some of those other
revolutions there was a degree of the
spectacle that pre
predated the technology so i think about
crystal palace in the 1850s and those
early battles for the light
the battles of the light bulbs in paris
in the 1880s right
and that's sort of 70 years before we
got to mainstreaming of electricity
and they were certainly in britain and
australia royal commissions and
investigations about what the
consequences of electricity would be
same in the united states there's a
quite famous congressional hearing about
domestic electricity at the turn of the
last century so definitely conversations
that preceded the ubiquity of the
technologies
and there was always in those previous
waves
a sense of there needed to be this kind
of moment where the technology and all
of its full potential was on display
and people went and saw it before it
ever came into their homes and their
lives
so i wonder in some ways if the
conversations we're having now with the
replacement of that
sort of the moral equivalent of the
crystal palace and the world's fairs
that what we're actually having is
something that at least has echoes in
the past though i think you're right
there
is a degree of conversation and
specificity about this one that wasn't
in the previous ones but i wonder if
we're also informed by that
yeah we know what happened in those
previous ones so now we're like wait i
have other questions
and do you have a sense of how the
degree of um i wouldn't call it
resistance but say criticism thoughtful
thinking skepticism
uh is compared to the is in this
revolution compared to the other three
was there as much
um ringing of hands and um
fear of it i mean there was the luddites
but i'm not really sure there was as
i guess there was a little bit in like
the computers when they first come they
were big and
scary do do you have a sense of how
this cycle compares to the of of
criticism and
skepticism compares to the previous
three
listen it's it's another good question
kevin i think all of those previous
waves were accompanied by
aggressive boosters and people with
utopian stories and equally aggressive
people with dystopian narratives
and you know the early stories about
electricity are kind of remarkable right
i mean there's a whole
fear in the united states that if we
electrify people's homes
women and children will be vulnerable
because you'll be able to see them at
home and so electricity at home was seen
as being really a problem
same with electrical cooking appliances
same with the you know
appearance of refrigerators all that was
seen as deeply troubling
we also know there was an inordinate set
of critical voices rehearsed in the
trade union movement as well as the
labour movement more broadly about mass
production and the loss of skills both
in the first industrial revolution and
the second
it's certainly the case when computers
were starting to mainstream that you had
a number of very clear voices in the
united states worrying about
automation there's a quite remarkable
manifesto written in the 1960s called
the triple revolution
that basically critiques the appearance
of automation
social revolution and defense funding to
say does this really build a society
that we want to live in it's a prescient
document when you read it
so i think those voices have always been
there they were just rehearsed in
different kinds of places right you know
you found them in the pages
of government handsards and
in lobby groups and also in the pages of
the newspaper i mean the kind of
uh stories about demonic railway
trains and runaway trains uh rife
through british newspapers and magazines
in the
1800s and unsurprisingly they were quite
dangerous objects right so i think that
critical voice has always been there
it just tuned in on different
frequencies i think that what's
also interesting you mentioned the
intentionality of things and how
something like the
steam engine was invented for you know
de-watering mines
um and you know we the fact that you
know
gps was invented for the military to
know where it is but all of these things
obviously get built into a world if they
work well enough
where they take on whole new lives of
their own and
and i think there's what you know where
does intentionality fit into ai i think
kevin you're famous for saying you know
there's a lot of new companies that just
need to take what they have and add ai
but what's the where does intentionality
really come into ai
zander i think it's also a question of
what are the longer term consequences
right we can talk a lot about the
transition from the atmospheric
engine you know by pumping water out of
mines to make them safer
to the railway system what we often
don't talk about is that in order to
make that railway system function
at scale we had to invent time so you
know one of the
really unexpected consequences of
railway expansion was that you had to
have this moment where
in order to share train tracks and in
order to make trains quote-unquote run
on time so to have a schedule that was
effective you needed to have a shared
agreement about time
and in england in the 1800s every town
had their own
time i mean there was greenwich maine
but not everyone used it so you had the
clock above the town hall and the mayor
would go out stand in the middle of the
square look up and
the sun was directly above that set the
clock at midday that's great but you get
a bit of variance between london and
glasgow
a couple of minutes which isn't much in
the grand scheme of things but when
you're running a railway is the
difference between a
catastrophic accident and not having one
and the railways all propose to create
their own time zone which they did and
they put a railway
a clock on every railway station and for
40 years in britain you had
local time and railway time and it took
an act of parliament in 1881
to make railway time into standard time
and so when i think about ai
i wonder not just about what is it that
people imagine they're doing with it but
what will be
the other quote unquote unintended
consequences
that will be necessary in order for
those systems to actually function
effectively
so i always think there's a question we
should ask about intentionality like
what is the world you imagine you are
building
and who are you to get to imagine that
and what does your imagination include
and
be silent to we don't talk a lot when we
talk about ai about how much electricity
it takes like you know storing data
and circulating data and curating data
and having access to data
is an extraordinarily energy intensive
thing
10 of the world's energy budgets spent
on server farms currently
that seems like uh hardly a conversation
you'd want to be silent to but it's not
usually the thing we lead with
hey your ai is costing electricity it's
not usually the first place we go
but frankly for me it is one of the
pieces that i keep wanting to pull into
the conversation when we talk about
intentionality is also the bit about
is this actually a sustainable thing and
what would it mean to ask a different
question about all of that
right so just as the previous
revolution invented time i think what
the fourth
the revolution uh is going to invent is
actually intelligence
we we have no idea what intelligence is
really and what it's going to what this
is going to do is actually
create this very vast landscape that's
much vaster than our concepts of it of
ourselves it's it's a
actually huge space of which our own
intelligence is one little corner of it
so
what it's going to actually create or
invent is actually intelligence itself
i mean the concept the the the the shape
of it the the it's right now it's a
amorphous vague hand waving thing but
it'll become a concrete
specific thing with dimensions and
metrics and things that we can actually
talk about in a real way and so
just as time kind of did exist before
the revolution it was
crystallized by it and we could measure
it in the same way
intelligence obviously existed but it's
going to become
manifest and um incarnated in a way
um that was not present before and it
will become a very specific thing that
we can actually
talk about scientifically yeah well
mccarthy one of the
early voices in the ai debates right one
of those original attendants of the
conference in 56 at dartmouth he was
very clear that if you got to a point
where these systems could think they
would actually believe
and he and i think turing too were both
quite clear that whatever the
intelligence of the machines would be
would be quite different than human
intelligence and it would require us to
then
have a much more nuanced debate about
what it meant to be intelligent and also
conscious and also sentient
yeah and that notion that kind of is
riven through the 1956 kind of
conference that
if we can just break down intelligence
into small enough pieces that a machine
can do it it's clearly the kind of
industrial revolution talk
but it's also clear that all the
participants there are secretly hoping
that they might get to something a
little bit more uh
both novel and i think or provocative at
some level
we have a question from one of the
streams david mccloda from youtube
um he's asking like what enduring
understandings about ai
should stem high school and i think you
could probably extend this into
undergraduate programs be paying
attention to
you know basically what are the
principles that you want your students
in your graduate program walking into
your program with
here at at the anu in the institute we
try to teach our students
three things and it's gonna sound a
little bit corny right i actually think
you have to engage people's heads
their hands and their hearts so all of
our students
learn the basic building blocks of ai so
they all learn
how to code it's python at the moment i
learnt pascal because i'm that kind of
vintage
i've had to use it in a long time but
knowing how it works helps you look at
most programming languages
so we teach everyone a little bit of
exposure to coding and to data
to algorithms to sensors all sort of
physical systems because it's one thing
to think about ai as code it's another
thing to realize it's mostly going to be
in physical objects that do things and
understanding that
interaction hugely important so building
blocks to ai
we also teach a set of foundational
building block
critical question asking because it
turns out i think one of the
most important things you can do and i
always realize i manifest it wherever i
go
is work out not how to build the
solution but how to ask
the right questions to get to the space
that a problem needs to be solved
not every problem that is given to you
is the problem that ought to be solved
it's sometimes not even the right
problem to articulate
so teach our students the building
blocks of the technical systems teach
our students
how to ask a set of critical questions
and always
lead with the proposition that whatever
you are building needs to
make the world a better place than it
was when you found it
which means you actually have to be
really clear about who are you building
systems for and why what might those
systems do
so for us it's an approach that blends
uh
lectures and reading with
lab classes and project work i hugely
believe that you have to be
in it with other people i think one of
the hardest things for us about the
experience of the pandemic here in
australia was as i know it has been for
many in the us
we're sending our students home and i
think for me being able
to have our students back at least a
little bit at the moment's been a hugely
important thing because there's
something about the way we learn through
our bodies and through our social
interactions
but if the question was what would i be
encouraging high school students to
think about listen i always go back to
norbert vena
and in 1950 norbert wrote this great
prologue to a play he was putting on at
mit
and he said that in the world that was
coming he thought that perhaps the poets
would need to be engineers or the
engineers would need to be poets
and i actually think in the 21st century
what i would say is the poets
should be engineers and the engineers
should be poets so i would encourage
people to do
both the stem field and then into the
humanities and the social sciences too
because i think you need to have both of
those pieces of the puzzle all the time
thanks um and just i wanted to make sure
we
are defining really what we're talking
about here too i think we kind of jumped
into this but
ron wolf uh one of the people online is
asking you know when we say ai
you know it's different than machine
learning which seems to be better to
find when you say ai what are you
where where are you where on the
spectrum of ai are you are you landing
so for me
when i talk about ai i am in fact going
back to 1956
and to the original uh formulation of
a.i
and the original articulation of it
where at that point ai
was described as um we want to be able
to so precisely describe
intelligence that a machine can be made
to simulate it and we're interested in
four things
a machine that will understand human
language a machine that would understand
abstractions and concepts a machine that
would be able to learn for itself and a
machine that would be able to ultimately
do things that humans could do
so when i think about ai absolutely it
requires data and machine learning
and algorithms and sensors and some form
of logic that holds all that together
but for me ai is not synonymous with
machine learning it's more than that and
i think the important pieces back in 56
and i would still argue important today
at that notion of both
abstraction and uh learning
and change over time so there was
another
um question from pete leiden
in the um in the streams and he was what
he was saying you know the
the first couple of um
revolutions may not be as as crucial as
this one because
they were basically driven by humans but
we have this
feeling that with the kind of ai that
you were talking about
there's there's another present there's
something else present
maybe guiding it than just humans and
that is
maybe a little scary because as you
describe
the ai just now that is almost kind of
other than human and so
that's what can set some people off as
well there's there's a whole other
presence here that's not just human do
you think that's true
listen i think our ability to make sense
of
and think about technologies is also
shaped by a much broader set of
conversations right
we're shaped by what we would talk of is
the socio-technical imagination right so
when we see a piece of technology we
also have a whole series of stories
in our heads about other pieces of the
puzzle so when we look at
intelligent systems somewhere in many of
our heads
there is frankenstein and the terminator
and maybe gollum and a few other pieces
of the puzzle that say
intelligent systems that aren't human
that's not a story that ends well
it's also the case that we have a very
hard time imagining
in certain cultural traditions what it
means to think of something else as
being sentient
or something else is having agency or
autonomy
uh and sometimes we tend to imagine in
the western tradition at least at the
pinnacle
as humans up here everything else down
here and humans are the only things that
get to be
sentient unconscious and thus also
acting
and so imagining that there are other
systems that may be self-reproducing
or learning or having conscience or
sentience seems
strange in our tradition and not always
in others uh
do i imagine that this is being guided
from elsewhere
not yet i'm not even sure that i believe
that it would be
uh my favorite roboticist is a japanese
roboticist by the name of mori
amori always sort of argues two things
right
one he at one point rather delightfully
wrote that he thought robots would be
better buddhists than humans because
they were capable of infinite patience
and infinite grace
and that's kind of a lovely conception
but he also says that our greatest
anxieties about computational other
are actually just a manifestation and
not just our
manifestation of our own anxieties about
ourselves and we project them on to the
robotic and artificial intelligent
objects
because ultimately whilst those systems
will learn
the way they will learn is still
governed and written by the rules that
humans write
and so if there's a thing to be fearful
in all of this i hate to say it may
still be humans
well it actually feeds into a great uh
this next question from jallu
um how much would the nation in which an
ai emerges i assume he means something
sentient
um have an impact on the personality and
ultimate goals of set ai so like
where do you are you already seeing
differences in
japanese systems and chinese systems in
american systems and european systems
listen my suspicion is one of the most
uh complicated pieces of this
conversation is we always make ai
singular we say
ai and the reality is we're talking
about ais and that sounds terrible with
an australian accent and probably not
much better with yours
but the reality is there won't be one ai
there'll be many and the reality is they
won't all necessarily
be even of the same valence or the same
sensibilities
so in one of the office buildings i used
to visit in sydney
uh there are three towers next to each
other and three different elevator
stacks
and each one of those elevator stacks is
running a lightweight ai learning system
and the elevators in each one of those
stacks behave completely differently
from each other
and completely differently from how they
behave three years ago in terms of where
they arranged themselves in the building
in terms of time between a button call
and a lift appearing
in terms of uh energy use and traffic
and over time those lifts
have diverted diverged from each other
and so if you take something as simple
as a lift and imagine three
instantiations all behave differently
because of the inhabitants in the
building
you have to imagine that multiple ais in
multiple countries will behave
differently
partly because they are built with
different sensibilities
so different ideas about what is the
world that they are inhabiting
from really straightforward and simple
stuff like localization strategies to
more complicated stuff like what is the
data that's being fed into them
what are the algorithms that are being
written in them what are the notions
about how things should and shouldn't
unfold
uh you know so the idea of an american
ai or an australian ai
not so hard to imagine i mean some of
the earliest instantiations of
autonomous vehicles
there was a large european manufacturer
who sent
their cars to australia to do an
autonomous road test because we've got a
lot of space here
um and these vehicles had been taught to
recognize certain kinds of dangers by
the side of the road and living animals
in particular
um unfortunately they'd been programmed
for big things with four legs
not bouncy things with two legs and uh
the
kangaroo problem turned out to be an
inordinate problem
we know for vehicles right when you're
looking forward you're trying to gauge
the distance between you and the thing
ahead of you
and the thing about kangaroos is they're
there then they go up and so as far as
the car was concerned they had
disappeared and then they came down
again not so much disappearing
if you're an australian driver you're
like yeah mate we know that but this
cocker was like
all not good and there was a period of
time that was really not good and i
shouldn't joke because it was actually
you know quite devastating at multiple
levels
but it was clear that that was a
technical system that had a whole world
built into it that wasn't ready to
contend with the world in which it found
itself and i imagine there'll be lots of
examples like that that are far less
benign yeah for sure i mean we have that
i mean
a more benign one is here in san
francisco you know everyone with their
track bikes which
they hold still at a stop sign by
rocking back and forth in their pedals
and so the autonomous cars
would always think that the bicyclist
was about to go and so that
autonomous car would kind of inch one
inch at a time across the intersection
uh it was pretty funny um but um i think
we're coming pretty close to the end
here do you have any ending questions
kevin yeah so um we're always interested
in the long term and how
these kinds of skills might be applied
to
a civilization you had this six
questions that you were sort of
asking um or trying to apply to this
revolution
what would success look like for your
program
in say 30 years or 40 years if you were
wildly successful
what would you think would be present in
the world that
isn't right now oh kevin can you be my
fairy godmother i love the notion that
i've got 30 to 40 years that's great i
keep thinking i have two
so if we are successful here over that
long horizon
i'd hope for three things i'd hope that
this discipline finally has a name as
opposed to what we call it now
the new branch of engineering which is a
terrible acronym um
i'd hope that we've actually birthed a
new discipline and that the
practitioners of that discipline much
like
their forebearers in electrical
engineering and computer science and
civil engineering
are now part and parcel of building a
world that we can all inhabit
so an established branch of engineering
an established set of practitioners
and ultimately both of those things in
service of actually building
a world that many more of us can inhabit
and a world that felt
slightly more sustainable and a lot
safer and a hell of a lot more
responsible so for me
what success there would look like was
actually building practitioners who
shaped a world that was a better place
for all of us
thank you so much genevieve this was
really great and
i really want to thank your technical
team in australia who did a fantastic
job
pulling this all together as well as our
technical team here on the west coast
of north america um and thank you all
for watching
um the jennifer can you just
say you one more time that you have
openings in your program this fall
and i think we had the url on there and
i know it'll be posted on the stream
so um yeah how do we find you yep we're
recruiting for our third cohort now we
start
in the uh we go on the calendar year so
we would start in february of 2021
we are taking uh admissions currently
or we are looking for our next cohort of
students uh we
have a pretty robust back set of
backgrounds and background stories
so you can find more information on the
web and i believe applications will
close in 10 days time so
if you or someone you know thinks this
is interesting please send them our way
cool well yeah i wish i could apply
right now
all right thank you love to have you
come will you promise that you'll come
visit when we can
let you back across the border trust me
as many places i want to go in australia
certainly one of them
thank you so much
[Music]
you